Die Impfungen haben begonnen.
Und jetzt fragt man sich natürlich:
"Wann sind wir da-ha?"
Also, wann können wir uns wieder in
knallvollen Bars in den Armen liegen
und laut singen?
Wann können wir unsere Masken
wegschmeißen?
Wann wird alles wieder normal?
Also, wir werden hier
kein Datum schätzen,
weil es von zu vielen Unsicherheiten
abhängt wie Impfstoffverfügbarkeit,
Logistik und so weiter.
Aber wir werden der Frage nachgehen:
Wieviele Menschen
müssen tatsächlich geimpft sein,
damit wir wieder ein normales Leben
führen können?
Oder: Wird es jemals wieder
wie vor der Pandemie?
Holt euch Tee, macht es euch
gemütlich, wir steigen durch.
(Quietschen, Knall)
2020 hab ich im Frühjahr gesagt,
es müssten 60 bis 70 Prozent
der Bevölkerung immun sein,
erst dann hätten wir Herdenimmunität.
Und dann wäre die Pandemie vorbei.
Allerdings ist das eine grobe Nähe-
rung, die missverständlich sein kann.
Also, Zeit für ein Update, denn
Vieles ist nicht so wie es scheint.
(Musik: "It Ain't Over Till It's
Over" von Lenny Kravitz)
Woher kommen eigentlich diese 60 bis
70 Prozent, von denen man oft hört?
Das ist eine vereinfachte Überlegung,
die etwas mit dem R-Wert zu tun hat.
Kurze Erinnerung:
Bei SARS-CoV-2 wird der R-Wert
laut RKI auf 3,3 bis 3,8 geschätzt.
Genauer gesagt sprechen wir hier von
der Basisreproduktionszahl R null.
Momentan schaffen wir es ja
durch Corona-Schutzmaßnahmen,
bei einem R-Wert um die eins zu sein.
Das ist dann die Effektive Repro-
duktionszahl, die wir R nennen.
Okay. Wie hängt jetzt der R-Wert
mit unserem Wunsch
nach einem normalen Leben zusammen?
"Normal" im Sinne von "wir können
alle Schutzmaßnahmen wieder aufheben,
ohne unsere Mitmenschen
in Gefahr zu bringen,
also alles wie vor der Pandemie."
Das ist nur möglich, wenn ein ausrei-
chend großer Anteil der Bevölkerung
immun ist.
Und zwar so viele, dass der R-Wert
ohne Schutz- und Hygienemaßnahmen
unter eins fällt.
Warum?
Angenommen, bei Corona
wäre R null gleich drei.
Dann wird ein Infizierter
drei Personen anstecken,
die jeweils auch wieder drei
und so weiter.
Wenn jetzt aber zwei Drittel
der Bevölkerung immun sind,
dann steckt eine infizierte Person
nur noch eine weitere Person an,
also R effektiv gleich eins.
Dann wird das Virus
zwar immer noch weitergegeben,
aber die Zahl der Infizierten
steigt nicht mehr.
Wenn aber so viele Menschen
immun sind,
dass ohne weitere Schutzmaßnahmen
der R-Wert unter eins fällt,
wenn also eine Person im Schnitt
weniger als eine weitere ansteckt,
sinken die Infektionszahlen
und irgendwann ...
läuft sich die Pandemie aus ...
und der Spuk ist vorbei.
Das ist die Formel, um den nötigen
Immunitätsanteil auszurechnen.
Wenn man hier für R null
drei einsetzt,
kommt zwei Drittel,
beziehungsweise 66,7 Prozent raus.
Daher kommen also
diese 60 bis 70 Prozent,
die viele seit Anfang der Pandemie
im Hinterkopf haben.
Am Anfang der Pandemie
ging man auch eher
von einem R-Wert von grob drei aus.
Inzwischen sind die Schätzungen aber,
wie gesagt, ein bisschen höher.
Das wirkt sich auch
auf die Herdenimmunität aus.
Bei R gleich 3,8
wäre die nämlich 74 Prozent.
Ihr habt bestimmt gehört,
dass es inzwischen neue Mutationen
des Coronavirus gibt,
die ansteckender sind,
wie die britische Mutation B.1.1.7.
Stellen wir uns vor,
bei einer ansteckenderen Variante
hätten wir einen R null von 4,5.
Dann bräuchten wir eine
Herdenimmunität von etwa 78 Prozent.
Bei R gleich 5 müssten schon
über 80 Prozent der Leute immun sein.
Allerdings ist das alles
ziemlich vereinfacht.
Zum Beispiel ist der R-Wert
nur ein Durchschnittswert.
Es gibt aber noch
die sogenannte Dispersion.
Dispersion heißt: Bei Corona stecken
viele Infizierte niemanden an.
Dafür stecken ganz wenige Infizierte
ganz viele auf einmal an.
Stichwort: Superspreader.
Und nur im Schnitt kommt man eben auf
3,3 bis 3,8 Ansteckungen pro Person.
Entsprechend ist auch die notwendige
Herdenimmunität ein Schnittwert.
Also, sagen wir, wir bräuchten im
Schnitt 75 Prozent Herdenimmunität.
Da kann es sein, dass in vielen
Fällen schon ...
ich sag mal, 50 Prozent
Herdenimmunität ausreichen.
In anderen Fällen - nehmen wir die
Karnevalssitzung in Heinsberg,
wir erinnern uns, eines der ersten
Superspreading-Events in Deutschland,
wo vielleicht fast alle
hätten immun sein müssen,
um eine Ansteckung zu verhindern.
Herdenimmunität nach dieser Formel
ist also ein vereinfachtes Konzept,
das nicht pauschal gilt.
Und die Geschichte
ist noch lange nicht zu Ende.
(Musik: "It Ain't Over
Till It's Over" von Lenny Kravitz)
Stellen wir uns
folgendes Szenario vor.
Irgendwann in einigen Monaten ist
ein guter Batzen Menschen geimpft.
Sagen wir, 30, 40, 50 Prozent.
Wie auch immer.
In Kombination
mit unseren Schutzmaßnahmen,
also, Kontakte beschränken, Abstand
halten, Schnelltests und so weiter,
kann es passieren, dass die
Infektionszahlen niedrig sind,
vielleicht noch weiter sinken,
Todeszahlen genauso,
R-Wert stabil unter eins ...
sodass es so aussieht, als würde
die Pandemie jetzt zu Ende gehen.
Doch wenn wir dann vorschnell denken:
"Tschö, Corona!"
"Auf Nimmerwiedersehen!"
und alle Maßnahmen fallen lassen,
wieder leben wollen wie zuvor,
könnten wir ein kleines bis großes
"Woopsie" erleben.
Woops.
- Woopsie!
Denn solange noch keine
Herdenimmunität erreicht ist,
ist der effektive R-Wert
nicht nur der Immunität,
sondern auch den weiteren
Schutzmaßnahmen zu verdanken.
Und wenn wir die
aus der Gleichung rausnehmen,
steigt der R-Wert wieder und es kann
zu noch einer Welle kommen.
Haha ... oh, woops!
In so einem Szenario,
wenn schon viele,
aber noch nicht ausreichend Menschen
geimpft sind,
könnte auch so was
wie eine Impffaulheit einsetzen.
Weil: Je mehr Menschen
geimpft werden,
desto normaler wird unser Leben
auch schrittweise werden.
Und wenn sich dann alles
bisschen normalisiert,
wenn wieder mehr auf hat, auch die
Krankenhäuser nicht zu belastet sind,
könnte man den Eindruck gewinnen,
"ist ja nicht nötig,
dass ich mich auch impfen lasse."
Aber sowohl das als auch vorschnelles
Aufheben der Schutzmaßnahmen
wäre ein voreiliger Fehlschluss.
Also lasst es am besten jetzt schon
mal in unsere Hinterköpfe kriegen:
Vorsicht vor einem Scheinende
der Pandemie.
Und noch eine Wahrnehmungsfalle:
Die Impfstrategie ist ja:
Diejenigen, die das höchste Risiko
für schwere bis tödliche
Covid 19-Verläufe haben,
werden zuerst geimpft.
Sowie bestimmte Berufsgruppen
wie Gesundheits- und Pflegeberufe.
Wenn irgendwann die Risikogruppen
geimpft sind,
kann uns schon mal kollektiv
ein Stein vom Herzen fallen.
Denn es ist eine große Erleichterung.
Wir werden nicht nur weniger schwere
Verläufe und Todesfälle haben,
sondern auch die Krankenhäuser
werden weniger belastet.
Gleichzeitig sind Menschen
aus Risikogruppen
nicht gerade die Pandemietreiber.
Gerade am Anfang werden die Impfungen
nicht gleichmäßig
in der Bevölkerung verteilt sein,
sondern es wird Safe Spots
wie Altenheime geben.
Doch für die restliche Bevölkerung
können Fallzahlen und Verbreitung
genauso sein wie vor der Impfung.
Bis also ein spürbarer Herdenschutz
für alle anläuft,
könnte es länger dauern als viele
vielleicht bisher erwarten.
Nächster Punkt.
Bisher wissen wir nur,
dass die Impfung verhindert,
dass man krank wird.
Ob man sich trotz Impfung
aber dennoch anstecken kann,
vielleicht ohne, dass man es merkt,
und das Virus auch so wieder
an andere weitergeben kann,
das können wir derzeit
noch nicht ausschließen.
Es gibt ja unterschiedliche
Antikörper.
Das ist Sandra Ciesek,
Direktorin des Instituts
für medizinische Virologie
an der Uniklinik Frankfurt.
Ihr kennt sie
vom NDR-Coronavirus-Update,
wo sie uns mit Christian Drosten
die neueste Corona-Forschung erklärt.
Es gibt ja unterschiedliche
Antikörper,
die wir unterscheiden,
also Immunglobuline.
IgM sind die Antikörper,
die als erstes kommen,
also die erste Reaktion
des Immunsystems,
IgG, die kommen danach,
und IgA sind typischerweise ...
Antikörper auf unseren Schleimhäuten,
die man vor allem dort findet,
wo die Ansteckung stattfindet.
Und, ähm ... die können verhindern,
dass es zu einer Vermehrung des Virus
von Anfang an kommt.
Das nennt man dann
sterilisierende Immunität.
Das heißt, ob eine Impfung
oder durchgemachte Krankheit
auch dazu führen, dass man andere
nicht mehr anstecken kann,
wird derzeit noch untersucht.
Man muss dazu sagen, dass die meisten
Impfungen, die wir so kennen,
schon auch die asymptomatische
Übertragung reduzieren.
Es gibt auch Ausnahmen,
zum Beispiel bei den Meningokokken,
aber wir hoffen,
dass es ähnlich ist
wie bei den anderen Impfstoffen,
dass es reduziert wird.
Das heißt, diese Formel
für Herdenimmunität gilt nur,
wenn eine Impfung
oder eine durchgemachte Krankheit
zu einer sterilisierenden
Immunität führt.
Ist dieser Schutz
nicht komplett gegeben,
muss die Impfquote höher sein,
um Herdenimmunität zu erreichen.
Aber warte mal.
Anderes Szenario.
Wenn wir mit Impfungen
plus Schutzmaßnahmen ...
die Infektion so richtig
runterfahren können,
so stark, dass das Virus
quasi niemanden mehr findet,
den es noch anstecken könnte,
könnten wir dieses Arschloch
nicht ganz ausrotten?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Und zwar deswegen:
Ich denke, 'ne komplette Ausrottung
ist unwahrscheinlich.
Das hat mehrere Gründe.
Das eine
ist die Verbreitung des Virus.
Wir finden das ja
in ganz vielen Regionen weltweit.
Und außerdem gibt es schon
die Beschreibung von Zweitinfektion,
also einer Reinfektion.
Immer wenn es
zu Reinfektionen kommen kann,
ist es natürlich schwer,
das Virus auszurotten.
Bisher sieht's danach aus,
dass man sich mit SARS-CoV-2
innerhalb von kürzerer Zeit,
also ungefähr einem Jahr,
noch mal infizieren kann,
allerdings mit deutlich
milderen Symptomen
und kürzerer Krankheitsdauer.
Dieselben Überlegungen gelten auch
für die Immunität nach einer Impfung.
Bei der SARS-1-Pandemie
von 2002, 2003 hat man es geschafft,
das Virus im Menschen
ganz auszurotten.
Beim neuen Coronavirus SARS-CoV-2
kann man aber nicht davon ausgehen,
dass das genauso funktioniert.
Das eine ist, dass SARS-CoV-1 ...
dass dort bei der Übertragung
asymptomatische und präsymptomatische
Übertragung nicht
so 'ne große Rolle gespielt hat.
Das heißt, dass die Übertragung
vor allen Dingen stattfand,
als schon Symptome
bei den Patienten da waren.
Und wenn man sich dann
bei Symptomen isoliert hat,
dann ist natürlich
eine Übertragung unwahrscheinlicher,
sodass man das
viel leichter containen kann.
Ein anderer Grund, warum SARS-CoV-1
sich nicht so verbreitet hat,
ist außerdem, dass das Virus nicht so
in den oberen Atemwegen
sich vermehrt hat
wie das bei SARS-CoV-2 der Fall ist.
Deswegen natürlich, wenn das
in der Nase sitzt oder im Rachen,
sich viel leichter
auf sein Gegenüber verbreitet,
als wenn's ganz tief
in der Lunge sitzt.
Das sind die zwei
entscheidende Unterschiede,
warum SARS-CoV-1 ja
sozusagen ausgerottet wurde,
aber SARS-CoV-2
sich weltweit verbreiten konnte.
Man geht derzeit eher davon aus,
dass das neue Coronavirus
endemisch wird,
also hier heimisch wird.
Nicht falsch verstehen,
dass man's nicht ausrotten kann,
heißt nicht, dass man's
nicht kontrollieren kann.
Deshalb sprechen sich
einige Fachleute derzeit
für die Langzeitstrategie
"No-Covid" aus,
nach der man einmal
in den sauren Apfel beißt
und für ein paar Wochen
alles richtig runterfährt,
um die Infektionen
nahe null zu drücken.
Um dann im Anschluss mit einem fast
normalen Leben belohnt zu werden,
bis die Impfungen durch sind.
Die Strategie soll ein Ausweg sein
aus den ständigen Lockdowns.
Denn je niedriger
die Infektionszahlen,
desto leichter lassen sich
neue Ausbrüche kontrollieren.
Und desto leichter lässt sich auch
die Freiheit aufrechterhalten.
Ich will hier aber
auf was Anderes hinaus.
Wenn wir das neue Coronavirus
nicht ausrotten können,
bedeutet das im Klartext:
Entweder man wird geimpft,
oder man wird sich früher oder später
mir Corona infizieren.
Nehmen wir diesen Gedanken mit
zu noch einem Szenario.
Stellen wir uns vor,
wir sind an dem Punkt,
an dem alle Risikogruppen
geimpft sind.
Ist das jetzt nicht der Punkt,
an dem wir,
vielleicht nicht die Pandemie,
aber zumindest alle Schutzmaßnahmen
für beendet erklären können?
Schließlich ist das Risiko für
einen schweren oder tödlichen Verlauf
bei Nicht-Risikogruppen
deutlich geringer.
Na ja, auch hier könnte es
einen trügerischen Punkt geben.
Wenn es auf die Endemie hinausläuft,
wenn das Virus irgendwo hingeht,
entweder wird man geimpft,
oder man wird sich infizieren.
Dann gibt es hier
durchaus ein Szenario,
in dem das geringere Risiko
von jungen Erwachsenen
wettgemacht wird durch
die schiere Anzahl an Infektionen.
Wenn man jetzt zu früh
alle Schutzmaßnahmen
wieder loswerden würde und das Virus
einfach so durchrauschen würde
durch die "Nicht-Risiko-Bevölkerung",
könnten genauso viele
Menschen sterben
oder schwere Verläufe
haben wie jetzt.
Die Intensivstationen
könnten sich genauso füllen.
Nur eben mit jüngeren
statt mit älteren Menschen.
Nur, wenn das Virus
nie wieder weggeht ...
wird's dann nie wieder
ganz wie vorher?
Wenn man so will:
Nein, wird's tatsächlich nicht.
Nur keine Sorge, ein endemisches,
also hier heimisches SARS-CoV-2,
ist lange nicht so schlimm,
wie es vielleicht erst mal klingt.
Selbst wenn eine Impfung
oder eine überstandene Krankheit
nicht vor Infektion,
also vor Reinfektion, schützt,
könnte eine Reinfektion so mild sein
wie eine normale Erkältung.
Also so ähnlich wie
die vier Arten von Coronaviren,
die jetzt schon bei uns heimisch sind
und zu unseren
saisonalen Erkältungsviren zählen.
Wenn wir jetzt also demnächst
entweder alle geimpft werden
oder uns infizieren,
danach das Virus aber
nicht mehr so gefährlich ist,
dann haben wir nach der Pandemie
und während der Endemie
folgende Situation:
Nur wer neu in diese Welt
mit dem einheimischen SARS-CoV-2
geboren wird, kann sich
zum ersten Mal damit infizieren.
Mit den anderen vier Coronaviren,
steckt man sich meist zum ersten Mal
zwischen drei und fünf Jahren an.
Das typische Alter der Erstinfektion
ist so das Kindergartenalter.
Wenn man das erster Mal
in große Menschengruppen gelangt,
dann findet ja häufig
'ne Erstinfektion
mit ganz verschiedenen Viren statt.
Wenn es bei diesem neuen Coronavirus
ähnlich sein sollte,
hieße das, nach der Pandemie
werden sich vor allem kleine Kinder
damit zum ersten Mal damit anstecken,
die ja ein sehr niedriges Risiko
für einen schweren Verlauf haben.
Bis diese Kinder dann
irgendwann so alt sind,
dass das Coronavirus,
beziehungsweise eine Erstinfektion,
so gefährlich wäre wie grade,
haben sie die Krankheit
ja schon längst durchgemacht
und können dann mit einem milden,
erkältungsähnlichen Verlauf rechnen.
In diesem Paper wurde modelliert,
wie die Sterblichkeit von COVID-19
in den Jahren nach der Pandemie
immer weiter abnehmen könnte,
wenn immer weniger ältere Menschen
sich zum ersten Mal infizieren.
Sollte sich allerdings herausstellen,
dass da Gesundheitsrisiko für Kinder
doch zu hoch ist,
dann wird Corona zu
einer der vielen Krankheiten werden,
gegen die man Kleinkinder
standardmäßig impft.
Was ist mit anderen Risikogruppen?
Es haben ja nicht nur ältere Menschen
ein erhöhtes Risiko.
Wenn man jetzt mal
Risikogruppen anschaut,
wie Immunsupprimierten zum Beispiel,
dann können die natürlich
schwere Verläufe haben.
Das sehen wir auch
bei anderen endemischen Viren.
Da kann man sich
die anderen Coronaviren angucken,
aber auch normale Rhinoviren,
die sind für uns junge Leute,
mittelalte Leute völlig ungefährlich,
aber können in ...
Vorerkrankten oder Immunsupprimierten
auch sehr schwere Verläufe,
die sogar zum Teil
tödlich verlaufen, auslösen.
Ich denke, das wär dann auch ähnlich.
Deswegen ist es ja wichtig,
dass um die herum
eine Grundimmunität da ist,
also dass viele geimpft sind
oder schon Antikörper haben,
damit diese Menschen
auch geschützt werden können.
Es ist dasselbe
wie bei anderen Impfungen:
Je höher
die Impfquote der Bevölkerung,
desto besser sind
die Menschen geschützt,
die sich aus gesundheitlichen Gründen
nicht impfen lassen können
oder die keinen ausreichenden
Impfschutz aufbauen können.
Was heißt das unterm Strich?
(Lebhafte Musik)
Ich würd gern was zu der Idee
"mit Corona leben" sagen,
die oft als Pandemie-Strategie
verstanden oder auch
missverstanden wird.
Nach dem Motto:
Lieber damit abfinden und anpassen,
anstatt Infektionen
weiter zu vermeiden.
Wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass
das Ausrotten nicht passieren wird,
dann ist die langfristige Aussicht,
ja, ein Leben mit Corona.
Doch nur, weil wir nach der Pandemie,
also nachdem wir durch die Impfungen
Herdenimmunität erreicht haben,
ganz gut mit diesem Virus
leben können,
ist es bis dahin
ja immer noch gefährlich.
Wenn nicht sogar gefährlicher
mit den neuen Mutationen.
Deswegen ist "mit Corona leben"
meiner Ansicht nach
keine Strategie für jetzt,
sondern einfach nur ein Ausblick
auf den Endpunkt, also auf das,
worauf es hinausläuft.
Die Frage ist doch eher:
Wie kommen wir an diesem Endpunkt an?
Mit wie vielen Toten,
wie viel wirtschaftlichen Schäden?
Mit wie viel psychischer Belastung?
Und hier gilt nach wie vor:
Alle Schäden und Belastungen,
von Gesundheit bis Wirtschaft,
sind umso kleiner, je besser wir
dieses Virus unter Kontrolle haben.
Deswegen finde ich
"mit Corona leben",
im Sinne von sich damit abfinden,
jetzt an diesem Punkt der Pandemie,
nicht so schlau.
Leute, es gab ja
in der Geschichte der Menschheit
noch nie ein Virus,
das eine Pandemie in diesem
globalen Ausmaß ausgelöst hat ...
gegen das wir eine Impfung hatten.
Dank der Impfung
müssen wir ja eben nicht
diese Pandemie
überleben oder übersterben,
sondern können uns wehren.
(Tröten)
Ich bin jedenfalls superdankbar
für all die Wissenschaftler*innen,
die diesen Impfstoff
möglich gemacht haben.
Damit wir uns eben nicht einfach nur
mit diesem Virus abgeben müssen
und der uns Spritze für Spritze,
ganz langsam,
aber Stück für Stück unseren
normalen Alltag wieder zurückgibt.
(Dynamische Musik)
Falls ihr dieses Video
hilfreich fandet,
teilt es gerne mit euren Freunden
oder eurer Familie.
Wenn ihr uns unterstützen möchtet,
lasst ein Like da.
Ansonsten für alle Freunde der Sonne
auch alle, die mir geschrieben haben,
vielen Dank dafür.
Mir geht's gut, mir ging's auch gut.
Ich war in den letzten Wochen
beziehungsweise Monaten
im Tunnel,
weil ich ein Buch schreiben musste,
beziehungsweise es
fertigkriegen musste.
Aber wir machen alles wieder gut.
Wir haben uns vorgenommen,
in den nächsten Monaten
alle maiLab-Folgen,
die jetzt ausgefallen sind,
auch wieder nachzuholen.
Das heißt, wir werden uns nicht
zwingend alle zwei Wochen sehen,
sondern manchmal auch jede Woche.
Ich freu mich sehr drauf.
Wir sehen uns dann
vielleicht nächste Woche.
Mal schauen.
Allerspätestens in zwei Wochen.
Bis dahin: Bleibt sicher!